So let's quickly review which properties I indexed.
The name property's indexed. We're very likely going to
want to search for conferences by name. The description
property is not indexed. We're not going to query
for the conferences by description. And it's actually fairly
typical, that if a property is going to have possibly
a long text string as its value, that you're
not going to index it. And city is indexed.
We're going to want to query the conferences by city.
For example, which conference is taking in place in Tokyo?
Which ones in San Francisco? In our case, the start
date is not going to be indexed. It's not that unlikely
that you might want to query conferences by start date.
It's just that in our case, we're not going to do
that. Now you could have figured out which properties are
indexed, by looking in the source code for conference. For example,
we see that name is indexed. Description doesn't have
the @index annotation. So it's not indexed. And so
on, for the rest of the fields. But an
easier way to check once you've actually created some conferences,
is just to look in the Data Store Viewer.
And the Data Store Viewer shows you which properties are
not indexed, by this little unindexed annotation. You've probably
already seen this. And that just means that the property's
not going to be indexed. You don't have to be Sherlock Holmes
to figure out that the converse is true. If you don't see
that @index mark here, then the property is going to be indexed. So
here we can tell that max attendees is going to be indexed. Now
that we've got some conferences, we can go ahead and learn how
to query on them. And Magnusson's going to talk to you about the
different types of queries. And then I'll talk you through how to
write the code to write the queries. See you in a minute.